this chess lawsuit is ass or is it it
all started when 31 year old Grandmaster
Magnus Carlson of Norway the top ranked
chess player in the world was dealt a
rare tournament defeat by Hans Neiman a
19 year old American Prodigy ranked 40th
in the world who some have dubbed the
bad boy of Chess due to his oddly
combative demeanor in interviews well
it's completely ridiculous that the
laptop is just running out of power like
plug the [ __ ] laptop in Carlson then
shocked the Chess World by accusing
Neiman of repeatedly cheating in matches
these voices only grew louder after
chess.com the world's largest online
chess platform concluded after a
weeks-long investigation that Neiman had
cheated in more than 100 online games
then banned him from the platform this
wild tale has all the makings of a drama
fit for a future Netflix series
especially given the salacious internet
rumors that Neiman cheated with the help
of an adult entertainment device put in
an adult entertainment location this
method of cheating of course was
pioneered by the famous International
Grandmaster Benoit now Neiman has
vehemently denied the cheating
allegations and respond to this
controversy the way that almost
guarantees that you end up up on this
channel by filing a 100 million dollar
lawsuit accusing the critics of
defamation and colluding to Blacklist
him from play and Destroy his career so
let's take a dive into the Neiman
cheating scandal break down the claims
leveled against Neiman his response and
whether the 100 million lawsuit has any
chance of success or whether he's going
to need a silver bullet now all of this
drama began on September 4th when Neiman
and Carlson faced off at the sinkfield
cup in St Louis despite being the lowest
ranked player in the tournament Neiman
pulled off a stunning upset against
Carlson in the third round snapping the
world Champs 53-match winning streak in
a post-match interview Neiman was less
than gracious I think he's just so
demoralized because he's losing to such
an idiot like me you know it's just it
must be embarrassing for the world
champion to lose to me I feel bad for
him Neiman attributed his victory to a
ridiculous miracle that he happened to
study the rare chess opening Carlson
used the morning before the game
allowing Neiman to guess how Carlson
would start
Carlson's move the next day was an even
more unusual variation pulling out of
the tournament for the first time in his
career and only providing context with a
veiled tweet Grandmaster and chess
streamer Hikaru Nakamura interpreted
Carlson's tweet as a veiled accusation
that Neiman was a cheater and then this
was the reason for Carlson's withdrawal
after the loss to Neiman at the end of
the day there's nothing um there's
nothing like nothing is proven but there
is a lot of Suspicion there is a lot of
Suspicion Neiman has a history of
cheating online on chess.com and was
banned there twice though Neiman has
denied cheating since his last band when
he was 16 and has stated that he has
never cheated in in-person game or when
prize money was involved I've never ever
in my life cheated in an over-the-board
game in an online tournament if they
were in unrated games following a game
on September 19th in which Carlson
resigned after the first three moves in
apparent protest the next day Carlson
implicitly accused Neiman of cheating
and declared he was unwilling to play
against people that have cheated in the
past Carlson tweeted that Neiman's
over-the-board progress has been unusual
and throughout our game in the sinkfield
cup I had the impression that he wasn't
tense or even fully concentrating on the
game in critical positions while
outplaying me as black in a way I think
only a handful of players can do this
game contributed to changing my
perspective on October 4th chess.com
released a bombshell 72-page report
concluding that Neiman has cheated much
more than he has publicly admitted to
including in many prize events at least
25 streamed games and 100 plus rated
games on chess.com as recently as when
he was 17 years old these findings
contradicted Neiman's public claims that
he only cheated twice that he never
cheated in price money events and that
he stopped cheating at the age of 16. in
support of their findings chess.com used
a variety of cheating detection tools
including a comparative analysis of the
moves made versus the moves recommended
by supercomputers a player's past
performance and known strength profile
the statistical significance of the
results and input from Grand Master
analysis well chess.com concedes that
there was no direct evidence that Neiman
cheated in his win at the sinkfield cup
the report did highlight some suspicious
elements specifically the report
addressed Neiman's apparents struggle to
discuss the rationale of his own chess
strategy after beating Carlson in St
Louis which top players at the time
described as at odds with the level of
preparation that Hans claimed was at
play in the game and the level of
analysis needed to defeat the world
chess champion but one might ask how
does a person even cheat at chess before
the story broke you might have been
surprised to see the words chess and
cheating in the same sentence but in the
words of the Washington Post chess has
long been in a game Rife with
allegations of chicanery in skullduggery
this this chicanery as technology has
advanced so too have chess cheating
methodologies these days people have
been caught using chess engines computer
programs that analyze games to recommend
the strongest possible moves chess
engines are so Advanced that they can
beat even the best Grand Masters every
single time make in 143 moves no pooh
you win again and in a video entitled is
this proof that Hans Neiman cheated
Nakamura reacted to a video from French
streamer yosha Iglesias discussing a
third-party statistical analysis of 10
games where Neiman's chess play achieved
a near 100 correlation to the perfect
moves of a chess engine according to the
analysis no other players not even
Carlson boasts so many 100 games and
recently players have been caught
cheating using chess engines on their
smartphones like George and Grandmaster
gaus Nick leitzay who at 25 years old
was caught cheating at the 2015 Dubai
open using a chess engine on the
smartphone he hid in the bathroom stall
Nicole eats A's Grand Master title was
revoked and he was banned from
competition for three years but what
happens if you can't access your
smartphone well one particularly
salacious rumor began to circulate on
Reddit that Neiman Could Have Cheated
using a well-placed Wi-Fi connected
vibrating adult entertainment device now
to be clear there is absolutely zero
evidence that this happened it's just a
Reddit rumor though it is technically
possible to cheat this way but for more
on this let's go to one of YouTube's
resident chess experts at Gotham chess
to explain more about these cheating
allegations hey everyone I'm Levy Rosman
also known as Gotham chess and I've got
the largest chess channel here on
YouTube thanks so much legal eagle for
featuring me in this video I'll try to
answer all the questions as best as I
can even though I'm here in a hotel room
so I'm sorry if the setup isn't as good
as yours there have been players in the
past like British slav Ivanov who was
found with a device in his shoe that
device was somehow registering good
moves and vibrating to indicate to him
something about the chessboard maybe it
was Morse code maybe it was something
else there was another case I believe it
was the French Olympic team in 2010
there was a whole elaborate system
somebody sitting at home was watching
the game live broadcast that that person
was then relaying something to a
middleman who was then standing in a
certain corner of the room itself to
relay information to the person that was
playing at the board let's think about a
very simple representation I would need
two squares or the first to to designate
which piece and the second where the
piece is moving that's probably the
easiest
what's the smallest amount of
information you need to help you
basically like a buzz in a critical
position that would be and what would
the buzz say it would it basically would
be something like one Buzz means the
position is is great and two buzzes
means the position is completely it's
completely equal or there's nothing
special in the position no it even
vehemently denies the cheating
allegations even colorfully offering to
strip naked before games to prove he's
not hiding anything they could literally
tell me the most ridiculous things they
want me to strip fully naked I'll do it
I don't care uh and well so far he's not
played in the nude he along with the
other players was subject to a full body
scan with a metal detector at the U.S
Chess Championship in St Louis which
takes us to October 20th when Neiman
made his next move by filing a federal
lawsuit against Magnus Carlson uh
Carlson's chess company play Magnus
Nakamura chess.com and chess.com
executive Danny wrench the complaint
demands at least 100 million dollars in
Damages from the defendants arising out
of causes of action for slander libel
unlawful group boycott under the Sherman
an Anti-Trust Act tortious interference
with Neiman's business and civil
conspiracy the 44-page complaint is
primarily a recounting of public
statements made by Carlson wrench and
Nakamura though it notably does not
address any salacious or unsubstantiated
internet rumors Neiman asserts that
there is no truth to the allegations
that he cheated at the sinkfield cup
claiming that quote unbiased top chess
analysts have concluded that his victory
resulted more from Carlson's
particularly poor play than Neiman's
exceptional play the complaint also
calls chess.com's cheating report a
quote false and malicious Hatchet Job
full of slanted analysis and that the
report's statement of Neiman's privately
confessing to additional cheating
offenses to Danny wrench is false the
complaint is full of effusive praise for
the quote American chess Prodigy Hans
Neiman and vitriolic insults for the
other defendants for example the lawsuit
claims that a corrupt and cowardly
Carlson chose to viciously and
maliciously defame Neiman with false
cheating allegations due to his quote
inability to cope with defeat at the
sink field cup after a man 12 years his
Junior quote dared to disrespect the
King of Chess the complaint accuses
Nakamura of joining in this defamatory
conspiracy because he viewed Neiman as a
quote threat to nakamura's dominance on
chess streaming platforms the complaint
also uses chess.com of colluding with
Carlson because the company plans to
purchase Carlson's play Magnus app for
nearly 83 million dollars in a merger
Neiman claims will monopolize the Chess
World though this merger was announced
in August before the cheating
allegations Neiman also alleges the
defense violated the Sherman Antitrust
Act of 1890 which Outlaws certain
monopolistic business practices by
colluding to Blacklist Neiman with false
and defamatory cheating allegations that
quote by Design destroyed Neiman's
remarkable career in its prime and
ruined his life Neiman also alleges that
quote defendants acted in concert to
improperly refuse to deal with Neiman
including chess.com Banning Neiman from
its platform and sponsored events
Carlson refusing to play Neiman in any
tournaments or events and defendants
acting collectively to cause organized
of professional chess tournaments to
Blacklist Neiman from participating in
their events so the 100 million dollar
question can Neiman win this case well
among legal observers the emerging
consensus is that Neiman faces an uphill
battle so let's start with the prayer
for Relief Neiman seeks 100 million
dollars in Damages and while that's
certainly a jaw-dropping number it has
zero basis in reality he certainly
pulled that one out of his ass whenever
someone files a lawsuit they can put any
number they want and in a complaint like
this that serves potentially to recover
damages but also serves to try and
rehabilitate someone's reputation uh
it's there to grab headlines which it
certainly did but in a case like this
any prayer for Relief whether it's one
dollar or 100 million dollars means
absolutely nothing but let's move on to
the rest of this lawsuit and start with
jurisdiction because Neiman has to show
why federal courts in St Louis even have
jurisdiction to decide this matter and
the fact that Neiman filed suit in
Missouri raises all kinds of questions
to hear a case a court has to have both
personal jurisdiction and subject matter
jurisdiction now subject matter
jurisdiction is a requirement that a
court has the power to hear a specific
kind of claim and for the moment it
seems that the courts having Federal
jurisdiction might make sense because
the complaint at the moment asserts a
claim for a violation of the Sherman
Antitrust Act which is a federal law and
uh there might be something called
diversity jurisdiction given the
residency of all of the defendants but
there's also the personal jurisdiction
requirement that the court has power
over the defendants based on usually
what's called minimum contacts with that
forum and the most common way to get
personal jurisdiction over a person or a
business is to sue them where they live
or do business or where the tort
occurred but here it's entirely possible
that some or all the defendants could
get the suit dismissed at least without
prejudice meaning that the suit could be
refiled given their lack of connection
to St Louis now Neiman lives in
Connecticut Nakamura lives in Florida
Carlson and his company are from Norway
and chess.com is a Nevada LLC while
wrench lives in Utah the only one with
any links to Missouri is Carlson who
allegedly made the defamatory remarks
that first arose out of his defeat in
the sink field Cup in St Louis so why
would Neiman Sue in Missouri instead of
his home in Connecticut well some have
speculated it's because of Connecticut's
strong anti-slap statute which dismisses
lawsuits that are brought simply to
retaliate against defendants exercising
of free speech which would have required
Neiman to show evidence for every single
element of his claims against every
single defendant to avoid dismissal and
in contrast Missouri's anti-slap law is
basically non-existent and it only
applies to comments and public hearings
which certainly wouldn't stop Neiman's
suit so let's talk about Neiman's
defamation claims if you haven't seen
are dozens of videos tackling the topic
of defamation definition is a tort that
creates civil liability for false
statements that injure a third party's
reputation Neiman has sued the
defendants for slander which is verbal
defamation and libel written defamation
but there are several barriers that
could make these claims hard to win even
if the cheating allegations are proven
to be untrue for starters definition is
only actionable if a defendant makes a
false statement of verifiable fact
meaning the assertion must be capable of
definitively being proven true or false
and opinions are by Nature not
defamatory if they nearly Express the
speaker's commentary based on Public
Information and here Carlson accusing
Neiman of cheating after losing at the
sinkfield Cub is probably not an
assertion of fact but a opinion based on
disclosed fact and as some have said it
may be a stupid opinion it may be a
wrong opinion but it's an opinion a
conclusion reached based on the observed
play not a statement of fact it can't be
defamatory and to Prevail Neiman would
have to prove that Carlson didn't
actually think Neiman cheated when he
made those claims a very high if not
impossible bar to clear similarly
Nakamura may be shielded from the
affirmation claims to the extent that
he's only giving his opinion and
commentary on Neiman's alleged cheating
based on public facts and not to fear
the same goes for a legal commentary
YouTube channel giving legal commentary
on a chess cheating scandal but the
complaint does suggest that chess.com's
conclusion that Neiman cheated is based
on on undisclosed facts and sometimes
implying undisclosed facts or explicitly
stating that there are undisclosed facts
can lead to defamation and the chess.com
report alleges that Neiman privately
confessed to additional cheating
offenses in a private August 2020 phone
call with chess.com's Danny wrench which
the complaint denies however the
chess.com report does include private
Communications between Neiman and wrench
between August 2020 and January 2021
that shows the zoom call took place
Neiman acknowledging being banned for
cheating and calling said consequences
completely fair and that's certainly
going to hurt Neiman's credibility
unless he can show that those private
messages were faked or taken out of
context another potential barrier to
recovery Neiman's Fame and notoriety
means that he could be classified as a
public figure subject to the heightened
actual malice standard to prove actual
Mouse which again has nothing to do with
hating someone one must prove that the
statements were made with knowledge of
being false or Reckless disregard for
their truth or falsity the actual malice
standard also applies to limited purpose
public figures which refers to to one
who voluntarily participates in a
discussion about a particular
controversy and has access to the media
to get his or her views across this is
opposed to the normal standard which is
just negligence with respect to false
statements but Neiman's almost trumpian
Praise of how famous and successful he
is that's contained in the complaint
only reinforces the idea that he should
be treated as a public figure subject to
the actual malice standard but that's a
double-edged sword because this
complaint is potentially to redress
grievances in court and get damages but
is also supposed to try to rehabilitate
Neiman's own reputation and get eyeballs
on it so it goes both ways but given
this high standard of proof Neiman might
not have any luck against chess.com in
court and as Bloomberg columnist Stephen
L Carter points out lawsuits by
individuals accused of cheating have
mostly been unsuccessful with courts
often unwilling to second guess a gaming
organization's own findings of
wrongdoing as an example Carter cites to
a 2010 Indiana case where a golf
teaching pro unsuccessfully sued a
colleague for calling him a cheat for
claiming a different classification than
the one to which he was entitled in that
case the professional Golf Association
agreed with the colleague's allegations
following an investigation and the court
dismissed the defamation claim because
the statements were true as Carter notes
the court didn't do its own
investigation rather the organization's
own judgment was sufficient to Shield
the defendant from liability and doubly
so it's hard to win an Anti-Trust and
intentional interference claim in the
absence of prevailing on a defamation
claim and those remaining causes of
action are also not particularly strong
based on the allegations made in the
complaint for antitrust claims in this
context it's likely that Neiman would
have to plead enough facts to convince a
jury that if true the defendants entered
into an actual agreement to Blacklist
Neiman but Neiman and chess.com are not
competitors and complaining the
chess.com and Carlson won't voluntarily
play with him doesn't necessarily
establish an illegal agreement and
simply alleging that the defendants did
similar thing things at the same time
isn't enough to allege an agreement in
Restraint of trade and additionally
tortious interference allows for a claim
for damages when a defendant wrongfully
interferes with an existing contractual
or business relationship the key there
being wrongful interference with an
existing contractual relationship the
complaint makes conclusory allegations
that defendants intentionally interfered
with Neiman's relationship with a series
of Chess related entities to coerce them
to terminate their relationships with
him and Blacklist him for future trade
but these are tough claims to make
because the complaint doesn't actually
allege any conduct directed at these
entities and to Prevail on a civil
conspiracy cause of action a plaintiff
has to prove that two or more defendants
again entered into an agreement to
commit a wrong and did actually commit a
tortious act in furtherance of that
agreement that caused injury to a third
party and Neiman makes conclusory
allegations that the defendants agreed
to do bad stuff to hurt Naaman but
doesn't actually provide the factual
basis suggesting an agreement to do that
and quoting Texas Judge John chupp three
people all liking the same cat picture
on the internet is not a conspiracy but
the thing about real conspiracies is
that you rarely have evidence of that
agreement at face value so if this
lawsuit does make it past the motion to
dismiss stage into Discovery I'm sure
the very first thing that Neiman will
ask for are all Communications related
to agreements between all of these
parties and who knows maybe those
agreements exist but to understand
whether Neiman cheated or whether
Carlson is being a sore loser it would
really help to understand statistics and
probability and today's sponsor
brilliant is exactly the place to help
brilliant is an online learning platform
for stem that replaces lecture videos
with Hands-On interactive lessons
brilliant is for Curious Learners both
young and old professional and
inexperienced and you can quickly learn
to Acer high school college math course
or just learn stuff that you always
wanted and in fact Brilliance data
science foundations course starts with
probability fundamentals and builds up
to using data and predictions
experimentation and neural networks
you'll learn and understand an
introduction to probability applied
probability statistics fundamentals and
eventually an introduction into neural
networks and then you can tell me if
Neiman cheated because brilliant let you
learn by doing rather than listening to
hours of boring lectures learning
through doing is scientifically proven
to be the most effective way to master
any new skill and the courses have
storytelling interactive challenges and
problems to solve you can sign up and
start learning for free today by going
to brilliant.org legaleagle or click on
the link that's on screen right now or
down in the description the first 200
people to sign up will also get 20 off
their annual subscription so by clicking
on the link that's on screen right now
or in the description you'll get 20 off
your subscription to brilliant plus
click on that link really helps out this
Channel and after that click on this box
for more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court